ja vielen Dank dass wir hier heute
berichten dürfen und unsere Erfahrungen
vorstellen können über die effektive
Nutzung der Kontakt Zeit mit
Studierenden in Blended Learning
Engagements
uns ist es wichtig heute dass wir ja
anknüpfend an den vorangegangenen
Vortrag nicht nur quantitativ diese 20
Minuten nutzen sondern dass wir auch
bestmöglich diese qualitative Vernetzung
zwischen den Vorträgen aber natürlich
auch mit unseren Themen hier schaffen
können
okay wenn wir uns für Planet learning
Engagements entscheiden dann geht es uns
vor allem um nachhaltiges Lernen
das ist unser Ziel und was brauchen wir
dazu
wir haben als Grundvoraussetzung die
unterschiedlichen kognitiven
Verarbeitungsprozesse und auch
Geschwindigkeiten von studieren und wir
müssen irgendeinen Weg finden hin zum
nachhaltigen lernen wir waren damit
nicht sehr zufrieden weil wir uns
gedacht haben der die Methode des
Vortrags ist einfach nicht
zufriedenstellend in der Hinsicht die
führt uns nicht so nachhaltigen lernen
deswegen haben wir uns entschieden den
Studierenden einfach mehr Zeit zu geben
für die Verarbeitung von Inhalten und
dann wenn sie das selbst tätig gemacht
haben in der Kontakt Zeit einfach
den intensiven Austausch über Inhalte zu
fördern und damit auch eine Vertiefung
zu erreichen und hier
vor allem kooperative Methoden zu
verwenden um diese Vertiefung in dieses
nachhaltige lernen bestmöglich zu
unterstützen
ja wir sind wir vorgegangen unser dreh-
und Angelpunkt erstmal wurde die
Lernplattform Moodle die haben wir
versucht ja vielfältige Angebote
bereitzustellen natürlich haben wir da
vieles durch Corona gelernt viele Ideen
aufgeschnappt erst notgedrungen
mittlerweile können wir aber auch ganz
klar sagen wir stehen da voll dahinter
hinter diesem Konzept
und ich möchte zunächst mal anhand von
einem Beispiel so ein bisschen deutlich
machen wie wir gearbeitet haben das hier
das Beispiel unseres lehrkräftetrainings
das lehrkräftetraining ist so konzipiert
dass wir den Studierenden verschiedene
asynchrone Lernbausteine zur Verfügung
stellen die ganz unterschiedlich medial
aufbereitet sind also von dem Podcast
bis hin zu Videos der ein oder andere
Text ist dann auch mal mit dabei aber
immer kombiniert mit Lernaufgaben die
wir für intelligent und sinnvoll
erachten um sich wirklich vertieft mit
den Themen auseinanderzusetzen
und das für uns dann entscheidende war
dass wir nicht wollten dass wir einen
Onlinekurs anbieten wo die Studierenden
so ihr Zeug abarbeiten müssen sondern
das ganze Wissen soll angewandt werden
es soll vertieft werden dafür haben wir
dieses Konzept von zwei praktischen
Übungstagen entwickelt
entscheidend während der
asychronen-phase ist dass die
Studierenden von vornherein alle
Lernbausteine der ersten Hälfte zur
Verfügung haben das heißt Sie können da
im eigenen Tempo agieren und sich die
Inhalte anschauen wir sind aber parallel
dazu
verfügbar das heißt wir mein Forum
eingerichtet über das Forum konnten
Studierenden oder können die
Studierenden alle Fragen stellen die
inhaltlich relevant sind damit Sie
wirklich auch effektiv arbeiten können
und zum nächsten Schritt weitergehen
können
eine zweite Veranstaltung die wir Ihnen
vorstellen möchten ist eine Vorlesung
die wir umgekrempelt haben dies
folgendermaßen strukturiert das heißt es
gibt Präsenztermine wo rein einfach
Sitzungen stattfinden es gibt aber eben
auch Präsenztermine die der asynchronen
Vorbereitung bedürfen das ist zeitlich
getaktete Studierenden sind jederzeit
darüber informiert waren was geplant ist
es gibt einen genauen Terminplan der
immer über Moodle das wie gesagt der
dreh- und Angelpunkt ist erkennbar ist
und es gibt auch das kennen Sie auch
wenn sie krankheitsbedingt ausfallen
oder Feiertage sind und die Zeit dann
einfach fehlt dass man eben auch
asynchrone Inhalte mit einem Workflow
zum Beispiel einbindet also hier die
Verknüpfung von präsentsetzungen mit
Atomen einmal so Vorbereitung und sowas
und thematisch sind Studierenden einfach
immer auf dem Laufenden über die
entsprechenden Struktur in Nudeln wo sie
so ultimatisch als auch Termin nicht
immer zuordnen können und so auch durch
die Inhalte und den Kurs oder die die
Veranstaltung navigieren können das war
die Idee
die beiden Kurse haben vieles gemeinsam
aber auch einzelne Unterschiede im
Folgenden wollen wir ein bisschen drauf
schauen was unsere Beweggründe sind bzw
welche Aspekte wir für als besonders
wichtige achten um ja so diese
Perspektive der Zeit hier mit dem Blick
zu haben
wenn wir also ein bisschen genauer auf
das Blended Learning Format schauen
haben wir uns jetzt heute mal sechs
verschiedene Bereiche rausgepickt auf
die wir jetzt ein bisschen genauer
eingehen wollen und ich beginne mal mit
den praxisrelevanten Kompetenzen hier
geht's darum dass wir die
ja die berufliche Laufbahn unserer
Studierenden von vornherein komplett mit
dem Blick haben vielleicht auch hier
noch mal anknüpfen es geht nicht nur um
die Ausbildung für gewissen Bereich
sondern es geht um die Bildung es geht
um die nachhaltige Bildung es geht um
den Aufbau von Kompetenzen die unsere
Studierenden brauchen um im Beruf
erfolgreich zu sein um den Beruf
bestmöglich gesund
absolvieren zu können und viele dieser
Kompetenzen können schon im Praktikum
erprobt werden natürlich dann im
Referendariat aber auch im Sinne vom
lebenslange Lernen dann auch nachhaltig
mit Relevanz sein
so der nächste Bereich den wir uns
angucken sind so lernpsychologische
Grundlagen die wie ich finde eine große
Rolle spielen sollten und da knüpfen wir
gleich an das an den ersten Vortrag an
an die Chronobiologie da geht es einfach
darum dass Studierende eine Wahlfreiheit
haben und zeitlich unabhängig sind auch
das anpassen können an ihren chronotyp
an ihren Rhythmus wann kann ich Inhalte
am besten aufnehmen wenn ich wohne
Inhalte habe
es geht einfach auch darum dass
Lerntypen berücksichtigt sind das heißt
wir versuchen Inhalte sehr
unterschiedlich anzubieten um jeden
Lerntyp zumindest ansatzweise gerecht
werden zu können also wie nehme ich
Informationen am besten auf das wollen
wir auch berücksichtigen und natürlich
geht's auch darum dass wir den
Studierenden wenn wir aschenkrone
Lerninhalt zur Verfügung stellen auch
die Möglichkeit der Wiederholung geben
also ich kann Podcast anhalten ich kann
noch mal zurück deswegen genauso kann
ich das mit Videos machen wenn ich
irgendwas mir noch mal anschauen möchte
wo vielleicht die Zusammenhänge nicht so
klar geworden sind und dadurch dass wir
noch mal Zeit zur Vertiefung im Seminar
oder in der Veranstaltung haben können
wir hier auch noch mal Wiederholung mit
ein bisschen zeitlichem Abstand anbieten
die Vertiefung erfolgt in beiden
Bereichen also in der eigenen Lernzeit
im Selbststudium durch die Wiederholung
aber eben auch im Seminar in der
Anwendung von dem wissen und wir haben
festgestellt dass die Wiederholung
bei den Studierenden erstmal so ein
bisschen auf ja Widerstand stößt und sie
dann aber merken oh das tut gut und sie
können jetzt um den Vortrag von Herrn
Noller aufzugreifen eine bessere
Vernetzung Erreichen ihres Wissens also
sie können Dinge besser miteinander
verknüpfen sinnvoller für sich noch mal
erarbeiten um eben die eigene
Lernmöglichkeit zu konstruieren
der nächste Punkt auf dem wir schauen
möchten ist das Methoden lernen
hier zeigt sich gerade bei Lehrkräften
dass es häufig Methoden gibt die erst so
in die Persönlichkeit verankert werden
müssen ins professionelle Lehrkräfte
handeln und unsere Erkenntnis darauf ist
dass es sehr hilfreich ist wenn sich die
Studierenden erstmal für sich entstehen
Kämmerchen sozusagen mit einer komplexen
Methode auseinandersetzen so die
Funktionsweise verstanden haben und dann
in einem praktischen übungssetting in
situationstraining zu erproben passt
diese Methode denn zu mir kann ich die
Methode körpersprachlich
präzise so durchführen dass es beim
Gegenüber gut ankommt
in den Praxis eine praxisterminen
arbeiten wir dann viel mit Feedback und
reflexions Phasen die genau darauf
abzielen dass die Studierenden
sich trauen diese Methode dann
vielleicht auch in realsituationen im
Praktikum beispielsweise auszuprobieren
und gegebenenfalls dann auch noch mal
die theoretischen Grundlagen zu
wiederholen ich freue mich natürlich
stolz gerade schon gesagt hat um die
Wahrscheinlichkeit der Anwendung der
Methode zu erhöhen
dann greifen wir ein Thema auf das wir
vorhin schon hatten weil Motivation ist
eine Sache die wir immer brauchen zum
Lernen und da beziehen wir uns auf die
Grundlagen oder auf dieses Modell von
die sind rein wir versuchen den
Studierenden Autonomie zu geben durch
die freie Zeiteinteilung das heißt dass
sie selbstbestimmt sich bestimmten
Inhalten widmen können wir versuchen
sowohl beim Selbstlernen als auch in den
präsenzsitzungen mit der Erprobung Übung
Diskussion Kompetenz erleben für die
Studierenden zu schaffen dass sie merken
es macht einen Unterschied ob ich etwas
weiß um oder nicht weiß und natürlich
versuchen wir sowohl über die
Kommunikation in Moodle wo wir
gruppenkommunikation um überfordern zum
Beispiel anregen aber eben auch über den
Austausch in den präsenzsitzungen durch
die kooperativen Methoden soziale
Eingebundenheit zu schaffen damit Sie
hier auch quasi Resonanzboden für ihre
Überlegungen haben und ehrliches und
kritisches
Feedback eben auch bekommen und
letztlich zielt es darauf ab dass sie
für sich erkennen welche Inhalte haben
für Sie persönliche Bedeutsamkeit auch
für ihre berufliche Zukunft also was
können Sie für sich mitnehmen wo sind
sie motiviert das dann auch in
realsituationen entweder im Praktikum
oder später im Referendariat oder als
Lehrkraft im klassischen Unterricht dann
umzusetzen
wir kommen zum vorletzten Punkt zum
Aspekt der Kontaktzeit
hier stehen für uns drei Punkte im
Vordergrund
anders als im klassischen
vorlesungsformat wo wir diese vorwiegend
ein wegekommunikation haben wir als
dozent:innen stehen vorne und referieren
berichten haben wir an unseren Blog
Veranstaltungen die Möglichkeit solche
Formate zu wählen die Kommunikation
fördern den Austausch zwischen den
Studierenden es geht ganz präzise darum
die Fragen aufzugreifen also
prozessorientiert zu arbeiten die bei
den Studierenden in dieser erst
Auseinandersetzung entstanden sind und
hier spielt die Verarbeitungszeit die
zwischen dem Erstkontakt mit dem Video
und oder eine Podcast stattgefunden hat
da werden die Informationen verarbeitet
bis hin zum Seminar dort entstehen
häufig neue Fragen die wir dann
aufgreifen und eben versuchen möglichst
treffsicher und genau die Bedarfe zu
decken
der letzte Aspekt der ist auch schon
angeklungen ist die Vernetzung das heißt
das Individuum mit der Gruppe zu
vernetzen und dem Thema zu vernetzen auf
unterschiedliche Art und Weise es geht
also darum sich persönlich mit dem Thema
in Verbindung zu bringen und das gelingt
unsere Meinung nach deutlich besser in
solchen interaktiven Formaten
ein weiterer wichtiger Punkt sind
natürlich die Lernziele was wollen wir
erreichen mit solchen Blended Learning
Engagements wir möchten die Studierenden
dazu anregen selbst zu reflektieren im
Bezug auf die Inhalte was passt zu mir
es ist im Lehrberuf oder als Lehrkraft
besonders wichtig dass man kongruent
echt ist also Dinge anwendet hinter
denen man steht und deswegen ist es
wichtig sich damit auseinanderzusetzen
nach einer Erprobungsphase ist das was
für mich kann ich das benutzen passt zu
mir dann geht's uns natürlich um die
fachliche Vertiefung aber gleichzeitig
auch um die kognitive Aktivierung das
heißt Inhalte sollen kritisch betrachtet
werden sollen auf Löcher überprüft
werden sollen dadurch eben auch vertieft
werden besser vernetzt werden mit dem
Vorwissen des Studierende haben und
letztlich zielt es auch darauf ab dass
sie kritisches Denken einüben Dinge
überprüfen nicht unwidersprochen stehen
lassen eben auch im wechselseitigen
Austausch mit den anderen Studierenden
und mit den Dozierenden und für sich
eine fachliche Position finden die auch
ja ausbauen und schärfen können
ja wir kommen zu den Herausforderungen
und benefit
genau also letztlich ist es so dass
natürlich die Aufbereitung der Inhalte
für Moodle im asynchronenformat in
deutlicher Zeit Aufwand ist also das
werden sie alle kennen aus der
corona-zeit wenn man ein tolles Video
machen will dann sitzt man da ganz schön
da lang dran von der Vorbereitung bis
zum Abschluss das ist natürlich durchaus
was was wir als Herausforderung sehen
und die andere Herausforderung liegt so
ein bisschen bei den Studierenden
nämlich die Disziplin zu haben sich
selbst termingerecht vorzubereiten das
kennen wir glaube ich alle so dieses
bitte bereiten Sie vor und dann fragt
man wer von ihnen hat den Text gelesen
und heben sich zwei Hände wenn sie
ehrlich sind also das sind mir als
Herausforderungen aber letztlich haben
wir festgestellt wie überwiegt für uns
der Benefit
einer der für uns wichtigsten Aspekte
ist die Verbindlichkeit das heißt genau
dieses die Studierenden müssen sich
selbst vorbereiten das kommt natürlich
schön zum greifen bei unserem
lehrkräftetraining wenn wir im Training
direkt starten mit einer Anwendung der
Methode dann ist es sehr ratsam und es
merken die Studierenden spätestens nach
dem ersten Block Tag wenn sie nicht
vorbereitet gekommen sind es lohnt sich
sich vorzubereiten der Erkenntnisgewinn
ist nur dann richtig gut gegeben wenn
beide Aspekte gleichberücksichtigt
werden also die Teilnahme an der Präsenz
stattfindet aber auch die ersten Krone
Vorbereitung im Vorfeld
diese Verzahnung
ist uns dann ein großes Anliegen und es
gelingt uns unsere Einschätzung nach
auch in diesem Format besser als bei
bisherigen anderen Formaten
was auch noch hinzukommt ist so diese
Kommunikation wir haben natürlich eine
veränderte Rolle für uns selbst wir
treten nicht als referenzinnen auf
sondern wir versuchen die den
kommunikationsanteil der teilnehmenden
zu erhöhen durch zeitlose Formate also
durch Methoden die anregen auch häufiger
mal in zwei Jahren Gespräch im kleinen
Gruppengespräch sich auszutauschen
wir wollen die Überprüfung der Lernziele
erreichen genau durch diese
kommunikative Anwendung des Erlernten
aber auch hier so auf diese Lücken zu
stoßen auf die Punkte wo die
Studierenden auch sagen aus dem und dem
Grund werde ich nicht ganz warm mit den
Inhalten die sie uns präsentiert haben
und dann können wir entsprechend
erklären gegensteuern oder natürlich
auch einfach annehmen dass vielleicht
die ein oder andere Methode nicht für
alle Teilnehmer die richtige ist
der Aspekt der Wiederverwendung ist der
Aspekt der Zeitaufwand ist hoch die
Videos zu erstellen aber ich denke auch
hier spielt die Chronobiologie noch
meine große Rolle wenn wir morgens um
acht gezwungen sind eine komplexe
Theorie darzustellen dann gelingt uns
das mal besser und mal schlechter wenn
wir dagegen das Video zu Hause aufnehmen
gut geplant gut strukturiert dann kommen
wir meistens stärker auf den Punkt und
dann haben wir es natürlich in unserer
Playlist und können dieses Video immer
wieder in Seminaren mitbringen
ein Zeitgewinn zeigt sich für uns auch
noch dadurch wir sind beide in der
Lehrer mit 16 Semesterwochenstunden das
heißt wir sind gut gefordert und wir
schätzen es hoch dass wir den Zeitgewinn
haben mehr Möglichkeit zu haben mit den
Studierenden in Einzelgespräche zu gehen
und ja auf die individuellen Rückfragen
reagieren zu können
genau jetzt haben wir in den vorgestellt
wie wir Veranstaltungen im Planet lang
Engagements machen und hätten jetzt noch
drei Fragen mitgebracht als Impulse die
wir vielleicht von Ihnen bekommen zur
Weiterentwicklung dieser Veranstaltungen
was haben wir übersehen was haben wir
vielleicht nicht bedacht welches
Potenzial sehen sie in so einer
Strukturierung und welche Aspekte sehen
Sie Ihr kritisch und damit würden wir
schließen und das Wort an Sie übergeben